I just want to start off with the
coronation it feels like such a big
story this weekend doesn't it what were
you doing yesterday ah I was watching it
on the television at home I thought the
the colors the the music everything it's
just a fantastic um spectacle it's
fantastic to watch are you a bit of a
royalist or do you know what I think in
this country we've got lots of people
who were staunch royalists and some who
sort of staunched Republicans I put
myself sort of somewhere in the middle
you know as a politician it wouldn't
surprise you that the things that were
in me day to day are things like the
cost of living and I want to talk to you
a bit about the police handling of some
of the protests as well um Lucy Fraser
the culture secretary said in that
interview she thought the police got the
balance right between allowing people to
celebrate the coronation without being
disturbed and allowing people to protest
peacefully do you think the police got
the balance right
um I've got concerns that they may not
have done we still need to see some more
information coming out about what's
some of that information is unfolding
but on the face of it I do have concerns
the fact is that in this country whether
you're a royalist or whether you are a
republican we should all be able to
agree on free speech and the right to
protest there is a distinction between
peaceful protests on the one hand and
disruptive and
um uh violent protest on the other what
concerns me is that the conservative
government have introduced very
far-ranging sweeping powers for the
police which affects all protests I
think what we may have seen yesterday
but we still don't know what we may have
seen is some of those new measures are
being used by the police I think that
puts the public in a difficult position
I think it puts the police in a
difficult position too and you're right
to say that some of these details need
to be investigated and followed through
but there have been talk of people
handing out rape alarms for example uh
being arrested someone with a megaphone
being arrested growing Smith the head of
Republic tweeted to say now that he's
out of the police station make no
mistake there is no longer the right to
Peaceful protests in the UK I mean that
is an incredibly troubling statement the
fact is that during the course of the
government's policing Bill and also
through the public order Bill liberal
Democrats made the point that actually
the police have all the powers that they
need they've always had powers to deal
with disruptive and violent protests I
think what worries me is that the
conservative governments have now
increased these sort of wide-ranging
powers to police or protests what they
haven't done is enshrined the sort of
legal responsibility and the duty on the
police to actually facilitate peaceful
process I was part of a cross-party
group in Parliament that actually looked
at this issue we took ever we took
evidence from people from the Met and
from protesters in the wake of the Sarah
everard vigil where the policing was
found in court to have been handled
really badly and as a result of that
inquiry that we LED we said there should
be a code of conduct around how protests
should be policed in this country we're
clearly a very long way from getting the
balance right I mean I guess look to put
the other side of this right we have
seen in recent years very disruptive
protests which have been made it
difficult for ambulancers to get through
people to make it to important Hospital
appointments because of a disruptive
nature of those protests that is what
the government would say they're trying
to stop
um I absolutely condemn those kinds of
protests I mean if I had been that woman
which I saw on the television who was in
her car desperately trying to get to see
her mother in a hospital I you know I
would have been probably even more Angry
than that that particular woman was so
of course um whether you've got violent
and disruptive protests they have to be
the powers to deal with that but those
Powers have already existed I think what
we've seen is the government has
introduced these new powers that apply
to all types of protests and therefore
there is a real kind of chilling effect
on the right to peaceful protest I think
it's time that the government would a
lot more clear about ensuring that the
police have a responsibility to uphold
and facilitate peaceful protests in this
country and we need a proper code of
conduct so the public knows where they
stand and the police know where they
stand so we can retain trust in the
police as well okay um I want to talk
about the local elections you had a
pretty bumper set of results uh shall we
say improving even on your 2019
performance which was a pretty high bar
I can see you smiling
um how would you describe them well it
was a record-breaking set of results for
us and we really did exceed all of our
own expectations and I think what we can
say is that we've obviously taken
control of a number of councils and this
weekend there'll be a number of the
conservative big beasts you know Michael
Gove Jeremy Hunt former prime minister
Theresa may even Nadeem zahawi who will
have woken up to having a liberal
democrat-run Council and they were
looking over their shoulder knowing that
we're now coming for their parliamentary
seats at the next general election so
are you the opposition then to the
conservatives in some of these the blue
wall absolutely there are many places
around the country around 80 seats where
the liberal Democrats key challenges to
the conservatives we call it the blue
wall area and we hope very much at the
next general election to win as many of
those seats as possible I mean I guess
some would say let's not get too carried
away the lib Dems always do well in
local elections and historically you
really haven't managed to break through
that much in terms of parliamentary
seats well you know I'm
friends I'm the MP for some Albans and
if you look at what happened there in
2019 we took control of the council in
the summer months and then just a few
months later we won the Parliamentary
seat as well so there is you know I am
living proof of the fact that you can
win at the local level and then using
that as a springboard to actually win a
parliamentary seat as well and that's
certainly a model we'll be using in many
other places across the country so the
results themselves pointed according to
Sky News analysis to labor being the
largest party but short of a majority I
just want
from the coronation if I may I think we
could have a look at that
okay starmer there and Adobe sitting
next to each other they're having a bit
of a chat at one point do you think
they're sort of could be a deal between
these two guys
I mean let's be honest
If I Was An Athlete and I said to you
I've got 12 months until I have to run
the race of my life and a journalist
said to the athletes well what are you
going to do the day after the athlete
would rightly say look I'm just focused
on that particular race and we're in
exactly the same position as politicians
as a liberal Democrat Deputy leader I'm
working with Ed to put our party on a
general election footing we have got a
laser-like focus on trying to get as
many liberal Democrat MPS elected as
possible when the general election comes
and we're just not even contemplating or
thinking about what might happen after
that at the same time though I'm not
sure I buy it because you've previously
ruled out a coalition with the
conservatives
why won't you run one out with labor
well because the conservatives are in
power at the moment it's abundantly
clear for us to see that's not um you
know relevant is it well absolutely
you're talking about potentials you're
saying you're not talking about this
because it's a possibility rather than a
reality why won't you rule out labor if
you're prepared to rule up with
conservatives day in day out we can see
the damage that the conservative party
are doing to our country you know
whether it's the NHS that they're just
driving into the ground whether it's
um you know the blowing a hole in the
nation's finances whether it's you know
continuing to allow water companies to
pump sewage into rivers and onto our
beaches we can see the damage the
conservative party are doing and the
reason that we've had those three
stunning by-election wins is because
lifelong conservative voters are voting
for the liberal Democrats in part
because they want to get rid of this
conservative government it is our
responsibility our moral responsibility
We Believe to outh the conservative and
ask there's many conservative MPS as
possible but as regards to labor I mean
they will stand on their own on their
own platform and we will stand on our
own platform we won't be defined by
another party we have our own set of our
open liberal values we're
internationalists we're
environmentalists we know we're
pro-business we're pro-public sector we
believe in devolving power to local
communities this is the platform that we
will stand on and we'll use every
opportunity between now and the general
election to make the case for voting
liberal Democrats so it sounds to me
like you would consider doing a deal
with labor as I say
um we have ruled out working with the
conservatives because of the damage
they're doing to the country but you
haven't ruled out working with labor
everything we do between now and the
general election will be about focusing
on getting liberal Democrat MPS elected
yeah but that's not the question I asked
that was it well that's what we're
planning to do everything between now
and a general election is getting
liberal Democrat MPS elected would it
change the voting system be a red line
in any live damn deal well it will
suddenly be in our Manifesto I mean it's
been in our Manifesto almost every
single election I think probably almost
every election since the formation of
the party and at the moment we have an
incredibly unfair voting system where
you know the political parties
themselves focus on a very small number
of votes in particular seats and a
number of people feel very
disenfranchised so it's very important
to us as live Democrats that we um that
we do have a fairer voting system it'll
be in our Manifesto and certainly you
know our main discussion well it'll be
in our Manifesto and it's a priority for
the party it always has been it always
will be how about rejoining the EU is
that over them for the lib Dems uh well
we would love to have the UK back at the
heart uh of Europe we've set out a four
stage plan as to how we want to do that
there are two very easy steps that the
government of the day could take today
improving our current trade deal and
rejoining you know other programs
whether it's education or science how
about the single Market well that's part
of our four stage plan eventually we
would like to end up in the single
Market we shouldn't underestimate though
how much damage to the trust and
relationship we have to EU with the EU
the conservatives have actually done the
damage has been really really
devastating I think as and when we have
managed to get a deal through recently
haven't they and actually EU leaders
tell me that you know they find where
she's doing like someone that they can
do it with but they can deal with yes
but in terms of you know rebuilding
their relationship with the UK as a
whole I think there's been there's been
a huge amount of damage done by this
conservative government liberal
Democrats want us to have the UK at the
heart of Europe and we've got that four
stage plan which will take us into the
single Market okay now last weekend I
asked Kirsten we're at Arsenal we're
going to win the Premier League he said
no so Auburn City a few leagues down
from Saint Albans from Arsenal um
they're in the playoffs today are you
confident they might get promotion oh
fingers crossed I'm pretty sure they
will come on the Saints
uh lovely thank you very much uh indeed
Daisy keeper there for the liberal
Democrats